I'm sure there were some racial things
thrown at you throughout the course of
your campaign there was but I will say J
when I was out campaigning around the
country I did not get much of that like
most Americans we're very open minded to
to me certainly to my face like I don't
know what happened like you know as soon
as I leave but like like when I was
there there was like a real warmth and
openness to to many of the gatherings to
the extent that I was frustrated with my
treatment it really was in the media and
I think that like that was tied to my
race
honestly like like that there was like
this invisibility that I was like what
the [ __ ] I'm standing right here and
like it happened to be frequently enough
where I was like oh this is certainly
not just me imagining [ __ ] and and I
think a significant amount of it was the
fact that I'm asian-american and you
know like people weren't accustomed to
having an Asian person trying to raise
their hand and saying like hey I've got
like I've got the solutions or like I
think I know where we need to go so so
that was a frustration of mine but it's
been invigorating that you know the this
movement has been growing really ever
like even after I suspended my campaign
like I feel like our energy is higher
now than it was even like when I was
campaigning